à première vue rien d'étonnant ici des
étudiants concentrés qu'ils écrivent
dans un café mais regardons y de plus
près ils sont tous assis à la même table
et ont d'ailleurs payé 5 $ pour y
travailler chacun leur côté sur leurs
thèses 5 $ pour se faire imposer des
règles simples pas de courrier
électronique pas texto pas de téléphone
on reste concentré 50 minutes puis on a
droit à 10 minutes de pause et on
recommence faut enlever la sollicitation
parce que si on le moindrement qu'on ne
peut figuration de notre sueur quoi que
ce soit ça on va complètement partie la
pression performance te demande d'être
tout le temps disponible pour être
sollicités pour des occasions de travail
et donc d'accepter d'être indisponible
pendant quelques heures c'est renoncer
aussi à certaines occasions qui vont
nous filer entre les doigts parce que
dans trois heures j'ai pas répondu à mon
téléphone
mathieu rédige une thèse de doctorat en
réadaptation tandis que geneviève fait
une maîtrise en théâtre peu importe tous
deux ont le même problème
juste la gestion des courriels c'est
vraiment un enjeu pour la grande
majorité des étudiants qu évidemment le
fait d'être connecté tout le temps mais
ça a une incidence l'heureux serait la
difficulté en fait que c'est de réserver
du temps sublime sur la thèse qui va
souvent arrivé après tout le reste
sarah mathieu on sait quelque chose elle
même doctorante en santé publique
elle est aujourd'hui aussi femme
d'affaires il y a deux ans elle fondait
ce groupe de plus en plus populaire
auprès des étudiants à la maîtrise et au
doctorat
d'après mme neuf ans il ya 50 % des
étudiants qui ont toujours pas terminée
c'est l'os est intéressant c'est oui un
groupe un taux important d'abandon mais
aussi et surtout un taux important de
prolongation on se retrouve avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'étudiants qui avait
plein de choses à apporter sur la
société dans toutes faites lorsque
l'arrêté gens même fait leur projet de
thèse mais qui ne publierons jamais
beaucoup de connaissances perdues
l'anthropologue samuel baissière
enseigne au département de psychiatrie
sociale de l'université mcgill
il suit de près ce nouveau malaise dans
la civilisation qui semble vouloir nous
priver de diplômes et les technologies
sont un des facteurs qu'on a identifié
mais un autre facteur qui a été mesuré
aussi dans une nouvelle génération c'est
que les enfants on passait beaucoup
moins de temps tout seul que les
générations précédentes
les parents sont tout le temps au dessus
de leurs enfants à les encadrer dans
absolument tout ce qu'ils font et ce qui
est important pour savoir s'autoréguler
il faut savoir s'ennuyer il faut savoir
aussi prendre des décisions tout seul et
il semble qu'on n'est pas vraiment bien
préparé la nouvelle génération pour ce
challenge là outre les rencontres de
trois heures taisez vous offre aussi des
retraites de trois jours où justement on
se sent un peu moins seul car j'ai des
morceaux de taille la rédiger qui sont
plus difficiles ou un nouveau concept
que je veux mieux comprendre et je vais
attendre dans une retraite entourée de
ses 39 personnes le puits soutenus par m
dans le silence je vais arriver mieux à
comprendre à rédiger donc ça ça va être
vraiment le les gros ne les gardent
souvent pour les moments où on est
plusieurs comme ça c'est vraiment ça
deviendrait d'action solidaire le fond
mais de façon parallèle marié va
tellement aimé les retraites de taisez
vous
kelly agit maintenant comme animatrice
de groupe on se met en rédaction pour
deux heures donc le les étudiants
commencent à comprendre le rythme tout
ça puis on fait d alternance avec des
activités de plein air
donc on évite vraiment les étudiants à
sortir à l'extérieur aller jouer dehors
comme on le fait avec les enfants
pendant les récréations et aux écoles
primaires aujourd'hui dans cette salle
il ya des étudiants d'un peu partout
ottawa sherbrooke trois rivières
certaines universités finances même en
partie ces séjours qui coûte 250 dollars
en janvier 2010
on est allé en france on est mené on a
accompagné une association qui a animé
une retraite de trois jours au sud de la
france à montpellier
il y aussi d'autres initiatives qui se
développe notamment à à paris puis à
angers
taisez-vous est tellement populaire que
non seulement on est en train d'exporter
la marque mais on ouvrira au printemps
un local permanent à montréal